well it is dangerous I mean it's  dangerous because Kanye has a lot of  followers I know he's now off Twitter  but you know he has a lot of followers  in the world a lot of people love Kenya  because he's an incredible musician and  a very big figure uh and so you know I  think however mad he gets uh what he  says continues to be taken seriously and  what he's saying uh is dangerous to Jews  because it implies that you know uh  beyond the Hitler thing uh which is just  you know gross and crass and offensive  at heart there's this idea that Jews are  somehow and obviously this is what the  Nazis believed as well as believing the  Jews are sub-human that the Jews are  somehow eating away at the fabric of  society and are able to control and  manipulate the rest of humanity in a way  that makes them alien but somehow also  you know the slave masters of the rest  of us and what that leads to is the  killing of Jews